well who here has experienced those
mysterious uh oh something's not right
in our app alerts
of us right well let's see how duet AI
can help troubleshoot
now I'm here in my email and I have this
mysterious alert I don't know what it
means yet but let's dig in to find out
here I am clicking on the incident it
takes me right into my monitoring
console and inside the monitoring
console I am reviewing the details of
this application error and sure enough
we see that there's a spike but that's
kind of what got us here but we are
interested in finding out if this is an
even bigger issue now in order to do
that this is a Prometheus query I'm
going to not want to write Prometheus
query and maybe write a natural language
um what are all of our other services
that are impacted so let me just say
show all services with this error this
should help us modify our Prometheus new
prompt ql which gives us only the all
the services that are impacted which is
exactly what we wanted great now we know
that this there are more services that
are impacted and they are checkout and
login and profiles so great okay we we
know a little bit more about our error
there are more this is a bigger issue
now
once we know this I really want to find
out why this is happening because that's
how we will explore
um our our actual solution so I'm here
in my log analysis log Explorer now and
we definitely see that there is an
illegal buffer now I want to dig deeper
I can click on explain this log entry
and this takes me right into dual AI
which pops up in the console in on the
right hand side here and gives me
information on what is going on with
this error and I can just ask
um the next question logical question
that I have is now why but how do I fix
this right so I would ask how do I fix
an illegal
buffer or any problem whatsoever right I
could just ask that question and do what
AI is right here in the console helping
me figure out what it is how do I solve
it and also provides me some links so I
can do a little more digging further
from here great
typically this would take me hours
across many different tools with duet It
All Happened inside Google Cloud console
in under two minutes powerful right